[Música]
directo a davos en Suiza Ahí está
nuestra enviada especial al Foro
económico mundial Daniela Blandón
Daniela la saludo ya muy buenas tardes
para usted vamos a hablar primeramente
de Estados Unidos y China que se
reunieron al margen de este foro
económico mundial en Suiza que se sabe
de este encuentro Daniela
Hola Raúl muy buenos días el datico
inicial menos cuatro grados estamos hoy
el clima ha sido bastante
condescendiente el día de hoy pues mire
Estados Unidos dicen que la reuniones de
acá del foro económico mundial son se
dan más afuera de davos que en el propio
davos y bueno tienen razón porque
Estados Unidos y China sus
representantes se reunieron en suricha
unas dos horas de acá para limar
asperezas Por así decirlo Janet yelen la
secretaria de estados de Estados Unidos
se reunió con ley quien es el viceprimer
ministro de China dijo que buscan evitar
que la competencia se convierta en algo
cercano al conflicto inclusive no
descartó que en los próximos meses o
semanas pueda estar visitando china Dani
también le pregunto qué más se espera en
agenda para el día de hoy
bueno la agenda gruesa está en la tarde
de hoy en la mañana un discurso del
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez como bien lo decía
Juan Pablo en su informe Pero va a haber
un foro sobre liderazgo en el que estará
presente los principales los presidentes
de América Latina que están acá
presentes Colombia Ecuador y Costa Rica
para ser más exactos habrá también un
muy esperado discurso de El canciller
Alemania es que Alemania está recibiendo
una especie de presión por parte de sus
socios europeos como lituania y Polonia
para que permita el envío de tanques de
fabricación alemana a Ucrania para
librar esta guerra contra Rusia algo a
lo que Alemania se ha opuesto firmemente
Pues dicen que que esto podría generar
un conflicto aún mayor Raúl Dani vamos a
hablar entonces de nuestra tan esperada
y tan querida cifra del día que nos
tiene
Bueno yo ya que había quedado viendo
este dato porque estábamos hablando del
altísimo costo de vida aquí en Suiza
pues le cuento que mi cifra del día son
los 6,71 dólares que cuesta un una Big
Mac esta famosa hamburguesa de
McDonald's Y es que the economist de la
publicación dije economistad fue muy
prestigiosa ha inventado desde 1986 el
índice que mide la calidad de vida o el
poder adquisitivo de cada país
dependiendo del valor de la hamburguesa
pues la de Suiza es la más cara en todo
el planeta este índice también mide
como la moneda de cada país está
infravalorada o sobrevalorada con
respecto al Dólar y resulta que la de
Suiza al Franco suizo también es la más
sobrevalorada la máscara del mundo Bueno
ni McDonald's puede comer no en caso de
un debate Dani pero Cómo podemos
aterrizar esa cifra para las personas
que nos ven en este momento
Claro pues Mire yo ya hice el cálculo
Usted sabe que a mí me gusta sacar
calculadora todo el tiempo y en según el
cálculo en Bolivia por ejemplo un
salario mínimo es de 323 dólares al mes
Con esos 323 dólares alcanza para
comprar 48 Big Max entonces una persona
tiene que trabajar todo un mes en
Bolivia si se gana un salario mínimo
para comprar apenas 50 hamburguesas aquí
en Suiza